somber thanks for joining us thank you
thank you have just announced the
winners of the prize in economic
sciences tell us who won so this year we
wanted to award research on financial
market prices and there are three
laureate sushi we share the price
there's Eugene fama from the University
of Chicago Lars Hansen also from the
University of Chicago and Robert Shiller
from Yale University so what did they
accomplished so their research has lots
been about you know how well do
financial markets actually work
financial markets are really important
for the economy because they decide a
lot on what people invest in how people
save so we really want to understand
whether these markets work well and when
they work well and or if we should do
something about it so that's basically
what their research has has been focused
on now it's been what we call empirical
which means that these all these three
researchers are about looking at data
and try to see patterns and financial
crisis and a lot of what they've been
working on is to look at whether you can
predict how financial market prices
behave in the future based on
information we have today now this may
sound a little bit mundane but it turns
out that this is a very important test
of how well markets work if markets
actually work well and prices are you
know correct then we wouldn't expect to
be able to foresee how prices are going
to move in the future and Jean Pharma
who started this line of research he
looked at what you could predict based
basically by looking at the stock prices
you know in the yesterday or a couple of
days ago whether that had any
information about how prices would move
tomorrow and he actually found that
there wasn't much such predictability
which actually would imply that
financial markets worked pretty well in
setting prices but it's possible to
predict the future in the longer run
exactly so this is where Robert Shiller
our second laureate came in so he
started looking at horizons on maybe
years decades and actually found that
you could predict how the stock market
was going to do over those types of
horizons Bay
some information today and in particular
what he found was that if you look at
how expensive stocks are relative to
fundamental values like the dividends
when stocks seemed expensive you
actually saw lower returns over the next
three to seven year period compared to
periods when stocks in cheap where is a
slider it just this means that does this
mean that you should buy high dividend
stocks well so this is not lit not
necessarily okay so and this is where
also Lars Hanson came in because if you
see that periods where the stock market
seems to have a low valuation and
returns are higher it need not be that
you know it's a good deal to buy stocks
it could actually just be that people
perceive the stock market is more risky
and investors don't like risk so they
don't want to buy stocks you know it's a
in recessions for example and to induce
them to actually buy stocks they need to
get be compensated for this and you
would then see this higher return but it
would be compensation for the risk that
they're taking so that's sort of one
explanation of this and Lars Hansen has
been very important in trying to test
these types of models it turned out that
the simplest models we had for this did
not really work and loris Hansen show
that with their methodologies so now
we've sort of trying to understand these
patterns and trying to understand what
we can build better models of our people
perceive risk and also try to understand
what extent these predictability is
actually because Marcus don't work well
that markets overreact or on the reactor
to information so but we've learned that
the market is always right it's a
perfect market so I but then again it
seems like there might so I think this
is where the results are very different
depending on what your eyes and you look
at so what farm I showed was it if you
look at over shorter I since days or
weeks you know we have no evidence or
very hardly any evidence that the market
wouldn't be right ok so the statement
that the market is right may be true if
you have a very short to rise now when
we start looking at these longer
horizons you know then it's not so clear
anymore but we always have to think
about okay is it because stocks are
risky or is there actually some
mispricing
so the markets are right in the short
run but less so in the long run at least
that seems to be what the data suggest
is we can't detect it's very hard to
detect deviations from efficiency in the
very short run at least deviations that
you can really profit from okay because
there are transaction costs in financial
markets while in the longer runs we
actually see this predictability you
know that seems to drive differences in
returns over time will the research have
any practical implications it already
has had considerable practical
implications so one example of this is
that you know when gene fama and his
co-authors came up with these results
that showed how hard it is to predict
prices in the short run that was kind of
important for practice because a lot of
practitioners actually spend lots of
time trying to pick the right stocks and
beat the markets over the next week or
month and this research indicated that
that may be actually impossible so as a
response to that and there was a new
financial product created called index
funds which basically just don't try to
pick stocks they just invest in a broad
index you know in all stocks in that
index and you can do that much more
cheaply than if you actively try to fix
talks and index funds have grown you
know by to norma's amounts over the last
decades and are now an you know
extremely important for households in
institutions when they invest in stock
so that's one exam and another example
is what we call modern portfolio
management so the what Pharma she
learned hanson also showed was that
there were certain factors like this
dividend to prize for example that had
some predictive ability and modern
portfolio managers now regularly use
these types of factors to guide their
decisions and whether they should invest
more or less in stocks versus pawns and
those types of things can you tell us a
bit about their background the laureates
background and so Eugene fama who is the
oldest of the three he I think his
background was actually in
languages in French I think and then if
i remember correctly he he thought that
you know being a French teacher doesn't
seem to pay that much time I'm gonna do
violence instead and then he did a PhD
at Universal chicago and then became a
faculty member in verse chicago and sort
of had a lot of impact since then and
he's been active since the sixties but
he still writes you know a number of
important papers every year which is
kind of impressive we have robert
shiller i'm not sure exactly where he
got his PhD but he's been active he's
currently at the yale university started
doing research in sort of the
intersection of macro and finance and
looked lot of interest rates in the
early 70s and then he had this huge
breakthrough with showing the
predictability and excess volatility as
it's called of stock prices and he's
been very active in last few years both
in research but also i sort of as a
popular writer to trying to bring these
subjects out to lay lay people and Lars
Hanson I think at his PhD at Minnesota
if I remember correctly and worked at
Carnegie Mellon University then came to
Chicago and he's been incredibly
influential in sort of not just for
asset pricing but generally to develop
econometrica or empirical methods to
analyze data
and it all across economics finally how
did they react when you call them they
were very happy they actually seem I
think the these are names that all have
been sort of in the discussion for a
while if you read blogs or newspapers
but they were still all three of them
seem very surprised and honored time
double the price and they also liked a
lot having got having received the price
together and they will be here in
Stockholm in December they will be here
in Stockholm in December and we will get
the opportunity to hear more from them
and I think they're going to be very
interesting discussions that all people
are very interested in debating these
issues thank you very much thanks